bold people make history so if you want
to be the lead actor of the of your
movie which is your life you've got to
take choices that might be contrary to
what you've heard
[Music]
when I was younger
um it was really romanticized that
you're going for it and just keep going
and you know it's like you have to work
24 hours do four movies in one time you
know five shifts don't sleep don't eat
and the more a person does that the more
successful you will be but as I have
seen and lived more life I've realized
having a work-life balance is really
important but to have a sense of passion
when you wake up in the morning for
whatever whether it's your job whether
it's your life whether it's your hobby
to have a sense of passion gives you a
sense of purpose and having a sense of
purpose really leads to success I think
you know I was learning the craft I'd
never been to school acting school or
anything so you know my my observations
were just you know what is everyone else
doing around me how can I learn and I
think that's something I still have I'm
a student of life I don't expect that I
know everything so when I ask for
something it doesn't come from a place
of I expect this done it comes from a
place of here's why it needs to be done
you know like I come with reason
um because I don't like
being told no to so I I make the
situation such that it's hard to say no
or I'll be like this is why it's
necessary here's why we should make the
change I'm not someone who likes
conflict I love collaboration I learned
and I tell young girls that specifically
girls
um but mostly for young people
confidence is it's self-taught it's
doesn't it's not something you're born
with it's not something that you'll
always have there'll be days where
you're completely underconfident and
don't feel the best my job I don't have
the luxury or yours to be able to go to
set and be like I'm having an
underconfident day we still have to do
this we still have to perform and I
would like to tell my younger 19 20 year
old self that you know
life is all Hills and Valleys it's never
going to be a smooth Road you will have
up you will have down but when it's down
you will go up so when you are up be
prepared for a down and it's okay
surround yourself by people that prop
you up surround yourself by people who
are genuinely happy for you it's not all
the followers not like the people who
you know you think are your friends that
you may party with but the ones that
pick up your phone call at two o'clock
in the morning the one when someone is
sick in your family that will sit with
you for hours overnight you know those
are the ones you collect those are the
ones you remember and those are the ones
you keep for the rest of your life
that's the biggest riches in the world
whenever life has been tough and it's
been tough many times it's been almost
down and out and you don't want to get
out of bed and you don't want to see
anyone I grew up
in the public eye so I kind of realize
that my best person was me I had to rely
on my skill set whenever I was nervous
or I was scared I I started focusing on
whatever was the goal in that moment I
never thought the canvas could be as big
as this this was not ever a aim or ever
even a thought I came from a family of
doctors Physicians military most of my
family has been in the service my father
and my mother both were in the military
so it wasn't a realistic ambition at
that time I come from a small town in
India my parents both highly Progressive
always pushed me towards whatever dream
I wanted to have I kept looking at the
next rung of the ladder and then slowly
I looked back and I was like 60 feet
above it is up to us and our generation
to be able to cut those ties and change
it for the next Generation so that they
don't inherit the equity on light skin
they don't inherit the gender equality
that we probably thought was normal I
thought it was completely normal and
absolutely okay to sit for hours and
hours on set while my male co-actor just
took his own time decided whenever he
wanted to show up on set is when we
would shoot it was normal you know when
fairness commercials came by and it was
a really big shiny brand it was it was
normal for actors to male and women to
say oh wow I have glowy white skin now
there was nothing wrong around it when I
was 21 22
I did think that I was dark-skinned I
did think that I was not pretty enough I
did think that I would have to work a
lot harder
even though I thought I was probably a
little bit more talented than my
co-actors or who were lighter skin I
thought that was right I thought that
because it was just so normalized so
when I was younger I didn't have the
um mental equipment to be able to deal
with how that made me feel I felt
smaller I felt invisible I felt like I
didn't deserve to be treated the same
way as everyone else because I thought
that that's what my reality was when you
fail whether it's in class or whether
it's you know in your whatever like any
dent
hurts when you work really hard
and you failed it hurts and especially
in my job right like my job is so
inconsistent think about it I don't know
where my next check is coming from till
I sign my next turn
so unpredictable that it's not like a
nine to five it's not like I get a
salary every month like think about the
basic of that it's really a simple
terrifying thought to do build a 22-year
career with that kind of inconsistency
takes a lot and it I think it's easier
for me when I'm more realistic about it
and I'm like you know what that didn't
work how can I make it better I have to
know that to be able to be better I
cannot be deluded I don't like being
deluded and I don't like deluded people
and it's just like
you can never please everyone and I
realized that very early in my career as
a public person when I was younger in my
20s I really needed everyone to love me
because I was a public person I was a
new Entertainer I was like why why is
this person hating me for this reason or
why is this being written about me for
this reason but I quickly realized when
you're a public person
you are consumed by people you're
literally dinner table conversation I
realize that the only way to protect my
sanity and myself was to surround myself
by people that are genuinely happy for
me that genuinely love and care about me
and my support system whether that's my
family my friends my team is very strong
so that I don't need my validation from
people I don't need my validation from
the comments on social media I'm not
working every day to be famous I'm
working to make movies to make art for
people to watch what I do and the
byproduct of that happens to be Fame so
once I've made that distinction and then
bifurcation I think it became a lot
easier for me to live a normal life and
and to just be a normal human being what
I would have told that girl is
just breathe and just chill a little I
was very hard on myself because
everything that I sort of everything
that I've made so far you know with the
encouragement of my family has kind of
been self-made you know I've I had to
learn on the job nobody I didn't know
anything I came from in high school in
an engineering background or I wanted to
be an engineer
um and life just kind of had other plans
and you know you kind of are you gonna
swim are you gonna sink and I will
always swim so I've just kind of
it's I think that what I would tell I
used to really take it very seriously I
berated myself a lot and I was hard on
myself and I would tell my younger self
chill out time heals everything
it'll all be fine
and what she would probably tell me is
to not get caught up in my schedule and
in the multiple things that I juggle and
not forget the excitement of doing what
I'm doing sometimes it's hard you know
after you do it for such a long time you
have to remind yourself to be excited
and be inspired and feel sort of alive
instead of it being a job I think like
you've got to sometimes you have to push
the envelope there's been too many
generations that have been defined by
what people think you know we can
achieve or
you know limitations that have been
imposed because of
people not being able to think or dream
big enough and I think it's every
generation's responsibility to show the
endless possibilities to the next
I think it's so crucial if you have a
choice in your life to end up with
someone who
is not like enthused by your dreams is
at least interested in them
is at least excited about them or you
know is at least
um encouraging
like that's that's exciting
um because you know everyone's busy and
everyone has a thing in their lives but
to take to make the effort to make you
feel like your dreams are as important
as the other one is such a gift in life
we never have to choose one thing so
that we need to take that pressure off
of our backs that you don't have to be
on one solitary Journey you can choose
to be on any Journey at any time as long
as you take the pressure we put too much
pressure on ourselves to function we
create boxes and glass ceilings for
ourselves because we're like oh this is
the only way I can be and that's how
you're successful there's no black or
white in the world everyone lives in
Grays
for me what has always worked is having
the small next dream The Next Step you
always have to take a step up in the
ladder to be able to get to the top you
can't get to the top by flying up human
beings don't fly and then slowly you'll
turn around and say oh whoa look at this
Legacy I've created but if you have
unachievable dreams something that seems
too out of the ordinary then you're
waiting for a miracle and miracles don't
happen very often you have to create it
for yourself so what's the next step in
your big dream so if you want to buy a
car say for example you have to figure
out how much it's for so you have to
work backwards from your goals so if my
goal is one thing I'll work backwards
and what is the first step in that goal
I'll take that then the next step in
that goal and slowly you'll buy your car
my mom said that to me when I was very
young
she said if you're gonna tell the truth
or if you're gonna tell a lie just know
that
um you know whatever you do you have to
stand by it The Good The Bad Ugly it's
all yours the sum of the opportunities I
chose is the reason why I'm here today
and I don't take that for granted at all
and that's my purpose is to make sure
that you know every single day is spent
with a pursuit of excellence in
um every single choice that I make